let's see if we can squeeze in
more people
let's go to is it
desmo or desmond from birmingham
desmoo
desmond you're on the air
hey what's up can you hear me fine yes i
can
cool cool
okay awesome um so i had a question but
i'm not sure if it's like better to like
preface my question with some like
context first probably not let's get the
question first and i'll tell you if we
need context
okay okay cool okay um
do you think that concepts like um
let me think of a good example of an
adjective okay it's fine i guess it's
not important do you think that concepts
uh
like um
social welfare policies
uh i guess i don't know if this is the
correct category to put that in but
things like uh
uh universal like single-payer
healthcare or like public more
affordable like colleges universal like
public colleges and stuff like that um
concepts like that that are
obviously a lot more like commonplace
within like europe
do you think that things like that are
kind of completely lost on the us
no
lost in what sense
kind of like um
like for example like i live in
birmingham alabama and if i tell someone
around here
that i think um universal single-player
healthcare is cool and that i think that
you know public college is cool
there they might call me a satanic
communist or something like that you
know what i mean yeah i mean listen
that's a very small slice of the
population
yeah i know that's that
oh there are people who may be against
these things for fiscal reasons or
whatever the case may be but
very few are going to say that you're a
satanic communist because of your you're
favoring that so no i don't think it's
lost on people at all and in fact i
would argue
that because of people's increased
understanding of the ways in which they
are getting screwed even if they don't
understand who's screwing them
i think that it's actually a great
environment now
to be talking more about the fact that
these are just basic not controversial
parts of many
western countries
economies and societies my friend i
gotta run i appreciate the call there's
desmond from birmingham i apologize i
cannot take any more calls today
but we will take more calls in the
future